they know party like a format party
because a format party features a
30-foot microphone cord good morning
Hank it's Tuesday today's video is like
the chambers of the human heart it comes
to you in four parts by the way I need
one normal shot so that when people look
at the thumbnail they think it's a
normal video and then I trick them and
it's a format but write part one Hank do
you know what this is It's the maternal
Center of Excellence a massive extension
to Sierra Leone's kodu government
Hospital funded primarily by
nerdfighteria that building at the top
left of the picture is a Maternity Ward
that will open this year incredible the
MCU is not a symbol of hope it's an
activation of Hope like I realize that
we don't have a word in English for When
Hope is realized which is pretty telling
but that's how I feel right now all
right let's get a quick check of the
weather it's hot it's just absolutely
disgusting it feels like I'm taking a
bath but the bath is made out of wet air
I hate it I spent half my life Gathering
up this 30-foot microphone cord and the
other half I wasted part two my current
favorite tuberculosis fact act comes
from rereading this book living in the
shadow of death which only appears to be
the third album by an obscure heavy
metal band anyway in this book the
author talks about how in 1852 when
Franklin Pierce was elected president of
the United States his wife was sick with
tuberculosis his secretary of state was
mourning his son who just died of
tuberculosis and his vice president was
in Cuba trying to cure his tuberculosis
also Franklin Pierce probably had
tuberculosis but he drank himself to
death before the TB could get him and
this isn't like ancient history this was
two human lifetimes ago the idea that
anyone is insulated from tuberculosis is
so recent we act like everything is
stable and normal and just as it should
be and always has been but that's just a
lie so much is so new which is actually
encouraging to me because it means you
know we can change it part three I know
sometimes it seems like I only think
about tuberculosis but I do think about
other things like how frequently the
fast casual restaurant chain Panera is
mentioned in hip-hop lyrics lately I
know right my God where'd you come from
oh I've uh I've been here the whole time
well can can you can you go away
that was easy like I first noticed this
in a Prof song called pack a lunch where
red man says I whine and dine at Panera
and then like a couple weeks later I was
listening to a young gravy song where he
mentions Panera and in that case it's
like he says like uh pull up to Panera
just to play a little foot see he
doesn't even have to say Panera it's not
even part of the rhyme he could have
said Fazoli's or oh Charlie's but he
chose Panera and that got me thinking
but then it turns out that a lot of
rappers are talking about Panera like
Lil Uzi vert Yes Rick Ross Lil yachty
the list goes on and on at some point I
started to wonder like is Panera paying
rappers to name drop Panera but I don't
think it's that I think it's that the
word Panera is just inherently melodic
all right part four oh no we have to go
outside for part four look at all these
peppers I Grew From seeds in my bathtub
that are now real proper pepper plants
we've got Habaneros and cayennes and
sweet peppers and everything in between
we've harvested over a hundred so far
but still have more than a thousand
growing which is great news from my mom
and I's annual hot sauce I'm making some
weird experimental hot sauces with the
early peppers and then we'll make our
traditional family hot sauce later in
the year hold on I'll show you the best
part the best part is burping them
because they're fermenting
anyway every year we name our family hot
sauce last year it was called societal
collapses in the air because that's
something Timothy chalamet said during a
press junket but we don't know what to
call it this year so if you have any
suggestions let me know in comments what
we're trying to communicate is you know
this is going to be hot but it's also
going to be fun
kind of like August in Indiana
Hank I'll see you on Friday